pour tourner ces cascades pour Mission
Impossible avec Tom il n'y a pas de limites
donc on devient un peu plus
aventureux à chaque fois que
Tom fait un sport très peu de gens sur
cette planète font ça s'appelle du speed flying
c'est un sport très beau et délicat
mais c'en est aussi un  des sports les plus dangereux
au monde bien qu'il puisse sembler
similaire le vol de vitesse n'est pas le parachutisme le
parachutisme est assez prévisible le
vol de vitesse est incroyablement imprévisible
c'est une très petite canopée dévalant les
montagnes à quelques pieds du sol, ils en
quelque sorte des vents de travers pourraient mettre Tom vêtements
nous  allons faire des spirales
et nous atterrissons à une vitesse incroyablement élevée
à plus de 80 kilomètres à l'heure,
nous nous entraînons depuis quelques années maintenant
et nous cherchons toujours quelle est la
façon la plus dynamique de tourner cette
cascade n'est qu'une des  les
défis techniques l'autre consiste à placer une caméra
dans un endroit où vous pouvez voir où Tom
utilise l'aile de vitesse,
vous ne pouvez pas vous en approcher avec un
hélicoptère ou un drone, nous avons donc dû
développer un système de cardan volant
avec Tom qui  avait des caméras suspendues des
deux côtés étant opéré dans un
hélicoptère ce qui va marcher c'est
ici c'est toi voici moi c'est ce dont nous avons
besoin
c'est l'une des choses de faire des
actions pratiques nous sommes à la merci d'un
temps
trop dangereux
le vent tombe maintenant n'est que  ça va aller
mieux allons-y allons-y allons-y
je suis prêt à
confirmer que vous avez des photos bon hé
véhicule avec caméra qui signifiait que Tom
devait atteindre le marché exact
ou cela pouvait se terminer par un désastre
[Musique]
c'est vraiment une aventure unique en son genre
étrangère
[Musique]